in other news tonight a startling
traffic trend in the las vegas valley
a woman was hit and killed in a crash
near charleston and fort apache today
the driver took off many who live in the
area say they're now concerned for those
on foot
madison kimbrough joins us live from
that area tonight and madison the big
question here
did police catch the driver they say was
involved
yeah so police did find the driver after
he fled the scene and we spoke to
several residents that say this area
is very high risk for pedestrians
it's tragic i've seen this a couple of
times where people
especially crossing the road and stuff
not and whatnot have been struck by
vehicles a 22-year-old woman was killed
after a hit-and-run crash it happened
just before 8 a.m
near the intersection of fort apache and
charleston
a 2003 dodge ram was going eastbound on
west charleston
when the woman whose identity was not
revealed tried to cross charleston
outside of a marked crosswalk
police say the driver of the truck fled
the scene and failed to notify police of
the crash
the man behind the wheel is 69 year old
richard madolo
thanks to security footage and witnesses
metro eventually found and arrested the
driver
phyllis clark is a local resident and
says it's a tough area for walkers like
herself
the lanes are so wide it's really hard
for pedestrians to actually get across
the street in a timely manner
there's just so much traffic going on
the cars don't watch for you
and i actually a couple times almost got
sideswiped when their people are coming
out of the
driveways metro made a plea back in
march of this year after an
overwhelming increase in unsolved hit
and run crashes
specifically in cases where drivers left
the scene leaving the pedestrians to die
on the side of the road
let that resonate with those who are
driving who think they can run
you're looking at 20 years in prison if
you would have stayed
you could have saved a life and that's
the most important message here
and according to metro the woman's death
marks the 29th
traffic related fatality of 2021 so just
in this year 29th the metro continues to
ask pedestrians
and drivers to really be aware of their
surroundings when they are
out on the roadways reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now